desde muy pequeño siempre he sido una
persona bastante distraída que nunca
podría estar más de dos minutos pensando
en algo concreto siempre tenía un millón
de ideas de una cabeza y no sabía qué
hacer con ellos
siempre me sentía un poco aislado de
todo lo que pasaba a mi alrededor
obviamente esto me causó como muchos
problemas cuando entré a la escuela el
jardín al colegio ese tipo de lugares de
instituciones educativas donde te ponen
reglas
básicamente la primera persona que tuvo
que lidiar con todo esto fue la señora
que está aquí
estoy más que seguro que a ella se le
ocurrió hacer esto conmigo y no sé por
qué ahora no lo hice pero
lo que en realidad pasó es que una vez
de ahí entró a la casa y me encontró
rayando la pared de su cuarto bien
concentrado al principio obviamente creo
que se debe molestado algo así pero
después se dio cuenta que ese niño que
no se podía concentrar en realidad
estaba centrada en algo por primera vez
en su vida y fue con un marcador y
utilizando como hoja las paredes
básicamente desde ahí yo empecé a
dibujar todo el tiempo hacía lo que
quería como en mi casa ese tipo de cosas
no me conoce cuando es pequeño y tuve
que ir al jardín finalmente de la
escuela y ahí se supone que tienes se
supone que tienes que seguir ciertas
reglas no es cierto entonces cuando tú
cuando yo entré al jardín yo no podía
seguir estas reglas no porque no
quisiera sino porque humanamente para mí
era imposible entonces
yo recuerdo puntualmente un caso donde
mi profesora del jardín yola casi a tal
punto que me puse en una esquina con un
montón de hojas y crayones y para rayar
él era feliz
no sé si pensaba eso lo que está ahí en
la imagen pero conociendo micro exija
bueno básicamente así pasa en mi jardín
tuve que ir a la escuela y ahí se
complicará un poquito las cosas porque
no era de las personas que podía pasar
seis horas sentada ha cruzado los brazos
y escuchando a alguien que no le
interesaban y no sé no me interesaba
escuchar lo que decía esa persona y me
sentía ahogado me sentía reprimido en
ese en ese lugar y lo único que ya tenía
como para subsistir en este momento era
el dibujo y eso no les gustaba a los
profesores a los que tenía en ese
momento
aquí haciendo un paréntesis como les
dije un inicio para mí era humanamente
imposible cómo seguir esta una porque no
quisiera sino porque no podía y solo
hasta hace tres años supe que eso se
llama ansiedad
esto obviamente no lo sabía ni mi mamá y
mis profesores ni siquiera el psicólogo
de la escuela al que visitaba casi todo
el tiempo
él dijo que era un típico caso de
hiperactividad cosa que era cierto
entonces entonces bueno con estas idas y
venidas del psicólogo que le llamaban a
mi mamá a la escuela para quejarse de mí
todo el tiempo logré no sé cómo por arte
de magia terminar la escuela entonces de
ahí tuve que ir al colegio obviamente
aquí las cosas ya se complicaron un poco
más un poco más bastante derecho y
inicialmente era porque tenía este
problema de ansiedad y se estaba
arriesgando en mí
mucho más y entonces también habían
estos chicos que medían el doble que
llevaban algunos
y también tenía a estos profesores que
me retaban como les dije como les dije
la única forma que yo tenía de controlar
toda esta ansiedad y todo lo que me
pasaba era dibujando y en la escuela al
no haber desarrollado ciertas al no
haber desarrollado mis relaciones
sociales
yo no podía mantener una conversación
con una persona normalmente en el
colegio y esto les molestaba mucho a los
estudiantes y también a los profesores y
ellos pensaban que no les prestaba
atención recuerdo que mi profesor de
física química a quien espero que esté
más calvo de lo que le conocí en ese
momento
me dijo puntualmente estas palabras con
estos dibujos mediocres no llegarás a
ningún lado y yo le creí en serio le
creíste estas palabras resonaron mucho
en mi mente y
entre un estado depresivo bastante
fuerte otra vez me sentí ahogado y
imagínense que llegara a tu casa a
acostarte dormir y no querer despertarte
esto es nada eso es un estado de la
depresión que ni siquiera sabía que
existía en ese momento
para mi suerte en esa época llegó algo
maravilloso mi vida que se llama
internet y en
en esta cosa mágica donde tenía todo lo
que a mí me gustaba donde perdía el
tiempo supuestamente empecé a buscar
miles de cosas que me llamaban la
atención y mentalmente buscando dibujos
para copiar este tipo de cosas encontré
este tipo de billetes que son de un
señor llamado kim o bueno que se llama
kino pero el buen salvador lavado y este
señor
recuerda que me llamó la atención por
dos cosas puntuales la primera porque yo
era igual de malcriado que mafalda y la
segunda porque ya había visto esto en
algún lado y no recordaba dónde era en
los periódicos que mi abuelo leía y eso
era lo que me pasaba viendo de niño
recuerdo que este empecé a ver muchas
entrevistas empecé a empaparme de todo
lo que es el humor gráfico y llegué a
otra persona que literalmente me cambió
la vida que es este señor que se dibuja
como conejo que se llama liniers él
también es humorista gráfico y hace
básicamente lo mismo que quino pero en
un estilo más onírico más mágico este no
se te recomendaba libros con unos
duendes homosexuales te ponía dos
pingüinos que te hablen que escuches
cierto tipo de música de bilbao y ese
tipo de cosas y me daban muchas cosas
para hacer y en realidad en ese momento
ya no me importa lo que me decían los
demás lo que me dijo ese profesor y en
serio dije si a mí me gusta esto
tengo que tengo que sobrevivir
a esta etapa de mi vida que fue el
colegio ya que sobrevivir de alguna
manera y lo único que conocía en el
dibujo empecé a crear mis propias
historias y recuerdo que este señor
líneas que les cuento en una entrevista
dijo que le gustaba una novela gráfica
que le cambia la vida y está la velación
a mouse mouse es una novela gráfica que
habrá sobre el holocausto nazi
básicamente el art spiegelman el autor
de esta obra que representa a ratones
siendo judíos a gatos siendo nazis a
perros sino-estadounidenses a los
polacos siendo cerdos y esto me voló la
cabeza en tantos niveles que en serio no
pensé que con unos simples dibujos tú
podías aprender tanto y ya no sabía que
estaba aprendiendo en ese momento
en realidad me causó tanto amor esta
novela gráfica que yo también quise
contar mis historias y empecé a hacer
mis historias sobre estos profesores que
me retaban todo el tiempo casi me
expulsan del colegio y por eso
y empecé a hacer todo esto empecé a
burlarme de mí mismo hacer humor
autorreferente a todo esto que me había
hecho mal todo el tiempo
en realidad aceptarlo y cuando ya tuve
que salir del colegio otra vez me sentía
perdido y mi mamá me pregunto cómo que y
ahora qué quieres hacer y hacer de que
no entonces
[Música]
en serio en realidad no sabía qué hacer
y récord está en la vela gráfica que es
de hecho una novela gráfica periodística
la primera novela gráfica periodística
que ha ganado el poliéster y dije bueno
a mí me gusta contar historias y por qué
no seguir periodismo y eso es lo que
empecé a estudiar entonces pero yo me
dije a mí mismo que no iba a
desperdiciar otros seis años de mi vida
dejando que los demás me digan lo que
debo o no debo hacer
y me dije a mí mismo que iba a poner mis
reglas para poder aprender y para poder
a mí mismo decirme que no era un
mediocre o un fracasado
y recuerda que mis profesores de
universidad / me mostraron muchos temas
interesantes de los que yo podía hablar
y contar historias les dije a ellos que
en vez de hacer mis ensayos en vez de
hacer eso quería hacer cómics y ellos me
dejaron y recuerdo que un profesor le
gustó tanto lo que dice que me dijo
porque no te abres una página en redes
sociales y subes tu trabajo si quieres
en realidad que alguna vez pase algo con
esto sobre tu trabajo en redes sociales
yo en principio tenía miedo y él me
preguntó qué porque yo empecé a hacer
estos dibujos y dije que era un juego y
él me dijo que el juego es lo es lo más
serio que existe entonces dejé ese miedo
y subí mi primera viñeta
a facebook la subida sin pretensiones
sin sin necesidad de que nadie la verdad
la subí y sólo muestra 34 amigos de sí
sin más
y les gustó y pasó algo increíble con
esto porque empiezo a creer a crecer
exponencialmente
todas estas cosas que me me pasaban
todos estos pensamientos que siempre mis
obsesiones todo este tipo de cosas que
me causan no sé esta ansiedad que les
decía que se estaban yendo a en estos
dibujos y eso prácticamente me salvó la
vida
recuerdo que recuerdo que ya llega un
punto en que me empezaron a escribir
muchas personas que les pasaba lo mismo
que a mí que no podían tener como una
relación social normal con otra persona
y ya me apareció algo bonito que alguien
se siente identificado con lo que yo
hacía a parte de esto me empezaron a
escribir otros ilustradores músicos que
colabore con ellos me cambió la vida en
180 grados todo lo que estaba haciendo
recuerdo que también la primera vez que
me publicaron en un periódico en el
diario el telégrafo yo no podía creer
porque me escribieron a quererme hacer
una nota y me dijieron básicamente que
les gustaba mi trabajo y todo eso yo
acepté me hicieron la entrevista estaba
muy nervioso como lo estoy en este
momento
no se fue la primera vez que madruga con
una sonrisa en mi cara a comprar un
periódico y literalmente fui donde la
señora del periódico le compré me
emocioné y le dije mire este soy yo vas
y en realidad no podía creer lo que me
estaba pasando y haciendo una
retrospectiva de todo esto me di cuenta
que está haciendo la educación con
nosotros qué está haciendo la sociedad
con ustedes conmigo
solo solo quiero terminar diciéndoles
que no es escrito de nadie que haya
seguido las reglas que haya hecho caso a
lo que digan los demás y si ustedes
tienen algo que les apasiona lo que les
mueve algo que en realidad hace que
ustedes se levanten de la cama y digan
en serio quiero vivir sigan haciéndolo
gracias